[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello hello hello
jus thank you for having us welcome to
the last talk of Jay s comp us very
exciting one of two things has happened
either we've saved the best for last or
they've pushed all the crap to the end
we're not really sure which but I think
we're about to find out but let's be
honest yeah I don't want to do this you
don't want to know this do ya let's not
do this we'll just go straight to the
party you don't want to do this come on
just get in the hot tub yeah who cares
yes so welcome to datura what is this
car discovering the true identity of
horse Jay s using machine learning I'm
Burke and this is Jasmine Jasmine we're
gonna pass this shirt and forth here
yeah so we we work at Microsoft we work
on the azure team and one of the things
actually you know before we start you
want to just tell about a little bit
thing a little bit about yourself Burke
specifically your shirt
oh sure so I have a show called five
things that we do anybody here seen the
show five things a couple right so a
couple of I think I work with most of
these folks thank you for being here we
have literally dozens of viewers it's
the hottest show on YouTube we have at
least two comments across 17 videos so
yeah that's me I'm from Nashville
Tennessee so on behalf of all the web
developers in Nashville thank you for
having me yeah yeah and as I mentioned
before I'm I'm from New York
I'm from New York but I lived in Florida
so I was really excited to come hang out
at James calm 2015 when that happened
and I just recently learned that I'm
emceeing
and purchase so this was like we held in
New York City so I'm excited yeah so we
like I said mentioned before we're gonna
add your team at Microsoft and one of
the things that our team does for
training is we have these these boot
camps a lot of us have backgrounds that
are not in Azure or sometimes not even
in with cloud technology so it's just a
great time for us to get to learn about
the platform learn about the cloud and
also a chance for us our team to get to
meet each other in real life because we
are a globally distributed and remote
team so we don't get to see each other
in person at all are often so this is
pretty much where the story starts right
Burke yeah absolutely
so Jasmine makes a gift when we're
actually not on the same team or in the
in the same organization but Microsoft
is sort of a large company so when we
say organization we mean like a small
country and so we work on different
teams inside of the same organization we
were at this boot camp and this idea
like most great ideas was born of pure
boredom so we were in this class on
artificial intelligence and machine
learning and it was a real deep dive
into actually building models we'd been
there for two days this is day two we're
sitting in the back we're highly
caffeinated we'd be eating Google
clusters all day if you don't know what
that is see me later I'll explain to you
the glory of a Google cluster and and we
stopped paying attention as one does at
the end of two days of workshop actually
I stopped paying attention to about
10:00 a.m. on day one that's that's a
problem I should probably get some
medicine for that I'm gonna look into
that but we're sitting there talking
about machine learning and and we said
what if we could use this great power to
do some real good things like
discovering the true identity of the
horse j/s twitter account and so we had
this idea that we could take a bunch of
data and we could just stick it up in
the cloud and then like we could just
say like Alexa who is horse j/s and it
would just tell us because that's how
machine learning works
of coure
everybody knows that and so that's how
the idea came about but who what is
force chance for those who don't know
Jasmine yeah sure you did you want
explaining worse chances oh yes you're
absolutely can obviously we prepared
we've rehearsed this many times we have
it down to a science so horse genius is
a parody account on Twitter and what it
does is it takes fragments of other
people's tweets
and it and it tweets them out and of
course there's no context it's taken
completely out of context and so when
you see the horse Janice tweet right
like that's great and a lot of times
it's almost poetic right you're like oh
that's exactly how I was feeling right
now so it's this it's this weird
it's this weird sort of effect and it
actually comes from a viral account
called horse ebooks if you're familiar
with that which was started by a fellow
in Russia who later actually sold that
Twitter account to someone it got so
popular and so we really we've been
following this account both of us have
but we really enjoy this right I guess I
get a lot of joy out of what his horse
Jay is gonna say next
nobody knows right and so from that was
born the project which we called project
horse yeah so so naming and anything's
is hard
Namie piece is hard right so so we're
gonna talk a little bit about the the
story of how we we went through the the
process of with process horse our
projects our excuse me project horse so
first thing we did is we gather some
questions other than just who is horse
genius we had some additional questions
to kind of give us some clues as to as
to who it might be and to get to give us
a end result and then we from those
questions we started drawing some
assumptions some things that we already
knew about like twitter users and you
know the tech Twitterverse are the
JavaScript Twitterverse and the people
we knew and so from that we had some
assumptions and then finally we moved on
to planning trying to figure out what
technology we should use trying to
figure out what our what our end goal
was and trying to figure out how to even
get started
and then then we went we're going to
talk about how we pretty much built
built project course and then finally
we'll talk about the results and we'll
talk about and and we'll expose to you
exactly who horse races now I know I've
heard I've heard that people have been
saying if they don't say who course Jas
is
I'm gonna I'm gonna freak out they
better not say something like oh we're
all horseshoe yes
oh yeah I see you're laughing because
you said it we know you said it yeah
exactly and when that I mean that's kind
of a given right we are hurt we all owe
hurt yes you know horse jss content is
you know pretty much it's it's us you
know and like when you saw that tweet
you you you Chuck a little because you
can identify with that you know that
whole I think therefore I am right thing
right you know but let's but before we
even get into the results we don't want
we want to make sure that we don't put
the cart before the horse
ah thanks welcome that's free that was
so uh so first thing so first we're
going to look at the questions that we
had so the first question that we
thought of had is we want to figure out
was horse Jess more than one person I
initially I thought the horse Jess might
have been a bot and so at first I was
like should we even do this maybe it's
just about maybe we just move on maybe
there's nothing here and then we and
then you know also again horse jess has
has had has been has been around since
2012 I believe and has over 7,000 tweets
so we were like that's that's a lot of
that's a lot of content to keep up with
it can it can really be just one person
so other question we had was what tweets
just horse [ __ ]
Jess react to what makes horse GS want
to quote your tweet what what what do
you have to say to make horse Jess other
than the word JavaScript right to have
horse jeaious react to your tweet or
quote your tweet we also wanted to know
when horse Jess was the most most active
because that could be some some clues
that expose expose who this person might
be and then also we want to know if
there are certain accounts that horse
just like to react to and figure out if
that if that could kind of give us some
clues as to if they're followers or if
they are actually following horse neighs
yes and then finally we want to make
sure we want to check in horses ever
slipped up and maintaining their
anonymity because for any grid and crime
there are an average of 20 mistakes made
that point directly to the perpetrator
so we're hoping that we'd find something
good in that data set that's actually a
true fact if you're thinking of
committing a crime just
no statistically speaking there are 20
things that you will forget about that
will point directly to you and you will
be caught thusly so that's what you're
hoping for right exactly so from those
questions then we started to think about
our assumptions and you want to talk a
little bit about that sure so we had to
go into this whole thing with a certain
amount of assumptions you have to start
from somewhere so you know after sort of
the question phase here we moved into
forming some solid assumptions off of
which we could sort of move forward and
actually do something here you know what
we're what we're doing here is is very
much sort of a forensic analysis which
is why it gets very interesting so the
assumptions that we had here the first
one is that that horse is an actual
Twitter user ok whoever is behind horse
is also an active Twitter user it is not
a bot if it were a bot it would be very
hard to catch because it does not exist
and so we started with this assumption
that that was the case we didn't know
that but we had to assume that to move
forward the second thing that we assumed
is that horse Janus is a web developer a
JavaScript developer a node developer
they are not someone who is outside the
industry right it's not a real estate
agent who works all day selling houses
and then meet in the you know on the
side is tweeting out things about
JavaScript if you are a real estate
agent and you're here welcome we're glad
you're here
but we just figured that was not you so
that was assumption that we made there
about horse Jay is important another one
that we made is that the person behind
horse jeaious is probably following
horse jeaious have you ever heard this
one the person who commits the crime
often returns to the scene of the crime
were you heard that before there's a lot
of crime analogies in here that's very
true and we figured that whoever horse
Jay s is they probably cannot help but
seeing themselves in their own timeline
and chuckling
at the cleverness of what they have just
birthed to the world and so we assume
that they are they're following that
account because they just can't help
themselves
sort of developing a psychological
profile here the other assumption we
made is that horse jeaious is a single
person now I don't mean like horse
jeaious doesn't date I mean like it's
just one I want to clarify that first I
don't think that has anything to do with
horse yes
if horse jas is more than one person and
actually I should clarify here we
actually operated under different
assumptions here you were you were
pretty sure that it was more than one
person and I was pretty sure there was
only one person part of the reason why I
was sure of that is because I wanted
that to be the case this is how I this
on my life works how I engage with
reality and so if you think about it if
horse j/s is one person that makes it a
relatively straightforward task in terms
of trying to find who it is if it's more
than one person now your analysis has an
exponent on it and the logic tree has a
ton more branches in it and there's a
ton more things that you have to chase
down so actually finding one person
would be much much much easier than
trying to find multiple people trying to
solve crimes where there's multiple
perpetrators involved as incredibly
difficult to do another something that
we made is that horse jeaious is not
using a private list and this is another
one where we sort of disagreed kind of
threw out Jasmine thought that they were
I didn't know what a private list was
because I don't know how to use Twitter
apparently but apparently you can have a
list of people that you follow that
other people can't see and so if you go
to the horse Janus Twitter account
they're not following anyone they're
following an account called horse
context that is in tweeted in years and
so you know I assumed that that account
wasn't following anyone specifically but
that whoever was behind horse j/s what
was happening was there there on the
internet they on Twitter they're like
hahaha and then they turn over to this
other account
the horse count and then they tweeted
out that was the assumption and then the
last assumption we made the most
important one is that machine learning
is the answer to everything it's it's
like SharePoint it solves all your
problems hey can we cut that joke out of
the video now I'm just kidding leave it
in and so again we're JavaScript
developers we don't know anything about
machine learning
we're not data scientists right we're
just we're just trying to use it because
everybody's talking about it and they
won't shut up about it so here we are
let's let's make it work can it solve
this problem so there's really
assumptions that we made and then the
most in question that we important
question that we had to ask at this
point was how in the world are we gonna
do this we used to have these calls when
we were first starting out where we
would just sit there and talk for like
30 minutes to an hour and at the end of
the discussion we just had nothing right
under the bit like we didn't know what
conferences that we were going to and
like you know how our summer is going
but we didn't really bother than that
and and so and I was starting to get
really really worried because after the
day after we had submitted the abstract
you know we we submit the abstract to
J's comp us they said hey
congratulations
and I called jasmine I said oh crap I
got some bad news I was hoping for an A
but they said yeah because
so we had to get started and we did not
know how to get started this was
actually the hardest part of the whole
project fortunately there's this guy
this this is Vadim this is actually dr.
Vadim Vadim works on the azure team and
he has a PhD in computational biophysics
I have a Bachelors of Science in
Business Administration Vadim is
slightly more qualified than me to solve
this problem so when we sat down and we
met with Vadim I explained to him what
we were trying to do and he said okay
and what is your data set and I said
it's Twitter all of Twitter is the data
set it was like ooh and then he told me
something that was that completely sort
of changed the trajectory of this
project and what he said was you don't
have a machine learning problem you have
a statistics problem now what I didn't
understand about machine learning is
that what machine learning does is it
takes statistical models that you've
already created and it crunches those
models to then make predictions about
what might happen in the future so for
instance you could take all of the data
about horse j/s all the times that it's
tweeted and then what machine learning
can do is tell you based on this pattern
it's probably going to tweet again at
this time what machine learning is not
going to do is create the model for you
and give you the answer that just does
not work and so what we had to do here
was was really not about machine
learning as much as it was about data
and data science there is another person
who works at Microsoft I actually don't
know where this guy works this is Matt
Veloso I'm not sure where he is in the
organization but he tweeted this and I
was like oh
if you take one thing from this
presentation so so the next time
somebody at your company goes we need
machine learning like what maybe you
don't you might just need a regular old
query tell them to it hold your horses
you just might need a query oh I wish I
could say that was the last one but it's
probably not oh all right
so this is this is a really important
fact and one thing that I I think that
you're gonna take away from this
presentation is that machine learning is
very powerful it's very interesting it's
a very remarkable technology but it you
plug it in when you need it and I think
the thing that we all struggle with is
when do I need it and the answer is I
don't know but as we walk through this
presentation we're gonna get to a point
where we actually do use some machine
learning and you'll see that it's just
one piece of the puzzle ok so a lot of
the things that you can do you still do
those things but there's gonna be that
one thing where you're like I can't we
would need an army of people to do this
and it's one thing and that's where you
plug machine learning in that that's the
hole that it fills so with that we were
ready to get started yes what do we do
well first thing we wanted to do was
grab all these tweets and put them in a
datastore no the challenge was was
trying to figure out how how far back we
wanted to go on how how much or how much
tweets how many tweets did you want to
collect so to help us with this we use
this account called horse-playing j/s
thanks thanks to Trisha wherever you are
thank you for for informing us about
this and this account this room was
really helpful because what horse Blaine
does is for every horse j/s tweet horse
plane comes in and mentions the purse
the the originator tweet and then quotes
the the actual tweet that they they
posted yes thank you very much was it
Patricia you said yeah
thank you and horse thank you yeah horse
plane has ratted you out let me just
tell you because if it wasn't for this
account there is no way we could have
gotten started it have been so so - yes
so so so we're like thinking okay how do
we get started of course we need to grab
we need to you know use Twitter API to
grab grab this data and put it in a data
store but how what what do we build and
what do we use to do that so we thought
of a serverless solution which is on the
top left here in this graph called a
juror functions it's a service
serverless solution that allows you to
do event-driven event-driven code
execution we were at Microsoft we have a
bunch of credits so and it's the fastest
cheapest way for us to do it we worked
on it look it's what the greatest thing
about working there is you just have
like all of as your like I'll just take
that whole data center for my project
for J Escom oh yeah et nos we've got it
right so and then and then we use we use
that to hit to get get our connect to
the Twitter API we use the 399 version
of that which you know can cause a few
like rate limit issues and I'll talk a
little bit about that in the next slide
of how we overcame that and then we put
that into a datastore and then we used
also cognitive services text API I do
some text analytics on some of the some
of the tweets and then out of all that
is was consumed by graph through a
four-horse just to figure out what the
results are well what the result set was
so we can kind of make sense of all this
data and and one of the important things
here is that this is just the API and
this took most of the time almost the
entirety of our time was spent just
building the API which is I feel like
how everything else goes right like 80%
of the work is spent doing something
that nobody ever sees but it's got to be
done we also learned some interesting
things about about [ __ ] DB because
cosmos TV uses the [ __ ] DB API I didn't
know much about it I still don't I don't
I would I said jazzing a message be like
can you can you please run this
aggregation query you have no idea
what's going on here and should be like
sure
and yeah my my browser history for the
last like two months has been
fascinating it's all it's all the
MongoDB document mine is like every
Stack Overflow post on MongoDB ever ever
I've been there I've been to every
single one so we learned a lot it was
very very difficult and there were a lot
of times we just wanted to quit right
yeah but how can you quit when you have
free free credits right right so just to
talk a little about the azure function
that we use we use this function we
called it our function half at horse
hunt because I mean obviously we're
hunting for hunting for a horse and what
the function app does is it hosts our
functions and then it's also a place
where you can add like configuration
file if it configuration so for example
we know Twitter the Twitter API we you
need need keys you need a token keys for
secret we're secret's out of your
firstborn child yeah exactly and and so
so the nice thing about that is that you
know you you have one place to add your
configuration and then all your
functions all your functions already
have access to all of that so you don't
have to you know copy and paste it you
know billions of times work for your
functions to work with the API or
whatever else you're connecting it to so
for so the first so we used to event
event function event based functions the
first one is a timer the timer the timer
event function and what that does it it
would run we had one that ran at 1:00
a.m. every day and it would get it would
collect the tweets from from the prior
day that horse yes that we didn't have
in our data store yet from the prior day
and dumped it into our cosmos TV
instance and then we came with the
challenge of backfilling going back as
far as we could
we went us back as far as as a horse
plane j/s account did so that we could
kind of easily run our queries and you
know and compare and compare the
original tweets and the horse tweets and
with that that was where we really came
across some reliving issues so we had
this we had a timer trigger or a timer
triggered function
would run run on a schedule and this
really easy to set up and used to do it
with a cron job and it would it stop and
eventually it was done when we told the
stuff we kind of had we gave it a few a
few dates a few dates and time and got
and collected as many tweets as we could
and then once that was done we we shut
it off and it's literally as easy as a
click of a button and then when we
wanted to consume that data we used a
HTTP event function and that was what we
used to to get all of our outputs for
our queries and our results so what when
it comes to when so in the end like like
Burke said we use pretty much built API
that collects the data puts in a
datastore and then also to query that
data now for a cosmos DB we we had a we
had so Kozma DB is a implication of
document DB I believe and what the nice
thing about it is that the the documents
your document structure will all look
just will will look the same but the
thing that differs is the API that you
use to to consume your data with so
there's different options for example
there's sequel Cassandra there's a graph
API yeah there's all kinds of stuff the
one we use as mentioned before was
MongoDB and in these two screenshots
here where I'm just it's just an example
of what the structure kind of looked
kind of looked like so we had a horse
object and that would contain the horse
J's tweet and some additional metadata
by the way which was like completely
empty horse Chase is really good at
covering their tracks and then we had an
original object which also had the
original tweet and some additional
metadata in that and then we when we
additional initially aside from also
consuming consuming the data and like
running queries to put in charts and
stuff to make sense of this data we also
used the cognitive services API
specifically their text analytics API to
run some analysis on the tweets so
cognitive Services is pretty much the AI
and ml that
you don't have to do we just kind of
it's pretty much just an API it has an
endpoint you give it you give it some
data or you give it some info and it
spits out pizza or gives you return
something back to you and the nice thing
about that is that we don't have to do
we don't have to build our models we
have to do anything we just had to just
hit an API endpoint which is really nice
so what you're looking at here is and
the the demo site for the text analytics
API and what's happening here is that
the SEMO you put on in some text and if
you can see here that I have a text or a
tweet from one of the the the data store
or from one of the text or text from one
of the tweets that was from an original
original one of the original tweets in
our in our cosmos DB instance and and on
to the right there we have we see it's
measuring things like sentiment and
keywords and things like that and then
on the bottom here we is an example of
what it looks like in our database or in
our in our database collection and or in
our collection excuse me and and what we
pretty much really ended up using was
the keyword sentiment was kind of cool
and what sentiment does is it's pretty
much measures whether some whether or
not text is positive or negative so
anything above 50% would be perceived as
positive anything below that's negative
and we didn't really use that but the
keyword the keyword really came in handy
for us right yeah and you'll see that
here in a bit how we use that but that
was that was interesting because the
sentiment is sort of what you think it
would be used for but that's not
actually what we used it we used it for
key phrase recognition and if you would
otherwise have to do by hand right that
would be fun exactly and like and we did
discover that using set the sentiment
analysis on hoarseness one wasn't going
to work at all because because it's not
it's a lot of it's just nonsense or
sarcasm and computers as it turns out
are not great with sarcasm true story
right and and in fact a horse some of
the horses tweets actually broke some of
our functions when we tried to like to
when we tried to get text analysis on it
because even like the text API would say
I don't know what you this is two words
this is not a sentence
sentence like this is not coherent I
can't help so so with that with all that
stuff we finally got some we finally
started to make sense of our day we
started to work on some of the results
so Burke you want to talk a little bit
about those results right you don't want
to talk about results do you want to see
this yes why did you waste so much time
already all right okay let's do it then
all right so here are the results from
all of the work that we did all of the
weeks of sifting through this data here
we go the first analysis that we did is
something called a time series analysis
now I'm about to make some broad and
inaccurate statements about the study of
Statistics because I am NOT an expert in
statistics so don't add me if you want
to come see me later at the party and
explain why I'm wrong I will be happy to
hear you out but for the purposes of
this talk grant me some leniency here as
I say some horribly wrong things here we
go
a time series analysis is when you look
at a series of events as they occur over
a period of time it's actually quite
simple I can't wait to hear how that was
so terribly wrong but I'm sure I messed
that up so the first thing that we did
was we we took all of the horse J s
tweets and we looked at them over a
period of time so let's do that this is
a graph a scatter of every single horse
J s tweet that we had in the database
something should pop out to you right
away
what do you see
they sleep ah are they really a
developer then now this is where this
really starts to get interesting because
what you're gonna see is the same thing
we saw which is that we would go in with
these assumptions and then we would run
these these queries and look at these
graphs and Riaan have completely
different realizations so you almost
don't know what you're looking for until
the graph reveals that to you here's
what's really interesting on the bottom
here what we're looking at are dates
okay so this is 2016 and this is up to
July over here on the side is supposed
to be time
this is chart Jas and I learned to
charge a s about three weeks ago so I
have no idea what I'm doing I tried to
convert it into 24-hour format on the
side but it's actually not correct let
me tell you what this chart actually
reads right here right here ish is about
10:00 p.m. Central Standard Time
okay right here where it picks back up
this is about 8:00 a.m. to 7:00 a.m.
Central Standard Time what does that
tell us they're in Texas that's right
or they are in the Eastern time zone
they are most likely in Central Standard
Time or Eastern Time most likely they're
probably not in mountain time because
that would be a bedtime of like 9
o'clock and they're definitely not a
Pacific time because it would be a
bedtime of 8 o'clock and waking up and
starting tweeting at 4:00 and that
definitely doesn't sound like a
developer to me except for a couple of
nights like right here in January this
is like 4:30 a.m. I don't know what
horse Jess was doing but there was a big
party in January also this one here this
was also a late night I don't know what
not sure what's happening there new
years it could been yeah exactly
but other than that they're getting a
good eight hours of sleep and they're
not active at night good for you horse
j/s healthy lifestyle choices okay
so the next thing we want to do here is
we want to look at the original tweets
the quoted tweets we're going to do the
same analysis on those tweets okay so
here's those tweets now what you'll
notice is that it looks kind of the same
okay we've got this big opening here
it's a little bit more populated but it
looks remarkably the same what can we
glean from that well we could assume
that possibly horse j/s is quoting
people that are in the same time zone so
they're quoting friends people that they
know people that live in close proximity
maybe again we're making assumptions
from the data here but we don't know
anything yet at this point I said okay
well let's do this let's overlay the
horse data on top of the original data
and see what we get I'm not sure what I
was expecting to find that just sounded
like something you would do with a chart
so this is what we've got now this is
interesting the blue dots are the
original tweets okay the the red dots or
the pinkish dots are horses tweets
now on accident I gave these things a
transparency of 0.5 because I thought it
was pretty but that actually was
interesting because what you'll notice
is there are some places where it is
pink bright pink see there you see there
you see there you know what's happening
there what's happening there same time
these tweets are occurring at almost the
exact same time some of them within
seconds of each other they doesn't lie
that is awful quick just saying so from
this we made this assumption that okay
if the tweets are very close together
let's say 60 seconds or less it's highly
likely that horse Jas is following those
people directly now remember I'm
operating under the assumption that this
person sees the tweet and then tweets as
horse J s okay so I said let's pull out
all of the tweets that occur within 60
seconds of the original tweet so let's
do that
there they are okay you'll see that this
there's like this one over here again I
told you I'm terrible at charge a s I'd
like to apologize at the charge a s
people their product deserves better
than me
okay so there's not a lot of them okay
now if we spread this out to like five
minutes to 10 minutes it starts to get
more interesting but then may that's a
lot of time on Twitter y'all five
minutes is a ton of time the other thing
is is that the analysis that we then did
from here is we said okay for each one
of these people let's get all of their
followers from the Twitter API okay and
then we can compare those followers and
see which followers do those accounts
have in common and that's how we're
going to get them
and that was an incredibly difficult
task here's why Brendan Eich was one of
those people and that dude's got like
200,000 followers West boss was one of
those people that guys got like 200,000
followers and what we really quickly
learned is first of all the Twitter API
just rate limited the crap out of us I
mean it was just all day long so that
was that was number one so basically
what you'd have to do is you would test
but then when she hit the rate limit
used to stop for 15 minutes and wait
some imagine that as a dev process right
sometimes I would just end our did we
just end our days like oh great limits
happen again let's just go he done so
yeah all right so what we did was we had
to set up these processes that would
recover by themselves so we did that and
here's what we found
all right so after all this what do we
know horse jeaious is probably in
central time or eastern time or the rest
of it was a vast waste of my time so
when it comes to frequency analysis I
don't have as good as a definition as
Berk does he as Brooke did for time
series or for the time series analysis
so I'm not gonna give you an example or
I'm going to show you the example of
what frequency analysis is and when it
hasn't released our project or project
horse so one thing that we did is that
we ran an aggregation query to find out
the people that horse Jess had quoted
more than five times and this is pretty
much answering the question what is
horse you know who does horse just like
to tweet whose horse just like to quote
and so from this we got some really
interesting from some interesting data
and some interesting results so if you
notice who you're your left guess your
left your left here that there is
somebody who has been quoted a lot of
times and then there's also a cluster of
people after that have been quoted
pretty pretty often as well and then
notice that
as as you move over to the right there
starts to level off a little bit and
level off a bit so it seems that
horseshoes has a circle of people or
other friends or maybe he's just or
maybe they are just a superfan or maybe
they are just reordered maybe they have
that private list I don't know I'm still
convinced and it might they might have a
private list but anyway but so we so we
kind of focus in on those on that right
we're right on that high number of
quotes that occurrence of recurrences of
quotes per account and we when we take a
look we took a little bit closer look at
that and we we use the metadata from
from those from those tweets to gather
some more info you want talk a little
bit more about that book yeah absolutely
so it's important to note that here we
we kind of decided that horse J us
probably tweets themselves a lot again
because it would take a lot of restraint
not to do that and we just feel like
that's not who that is
that just that to us just does not
restraint does not sound like horse
neighs so what you're looking at here is
a Graham app here of all of the people
that live in either central or Eastern
time there's only six of all these
people and yes I know the names are
bordered at the bottom we're trying to
obscure some data here of all of these
people only six one of them is in Texas
and there are five in the New York area
all right so from this we can again make
a few assumptions about horse jeaious we
could make the assumption and we sort of
did that horse jeaious probably lives in
the New York area also of these other
four people that are in the New York
area with them almost all of those
people are on the left side of this
chart so it is highly likely that horse
a s is in New York or the New York area
they have a group of friends in that
area they are they are quoting those
people because their friends and it's
funny so we decided from this
that horse Jas lives in the Eastern time
zone which took us to the next part in
which we learned about some machine
learning yeah so this is the output of
the text analysis that we got and so so
like I showed you before we put all our
text analysis in a separate collection
ran an aggregate query I got really good
at arrogation if you if you ever need
everybody I had never used MongoDB
before so it was a learning experience
to start a consulting service for good
to be aggregation queries and what we
did is rent aggregation query on all the
keywords we want to kind of figure out
this is kind of answering the question
what does what makes horse GS tweet our
quote specific tweets what what are the
keywords that makes horse jeaious want
to want to quote a tweet and if you take
a look here so actually so on the left
here the first two there are kind of
kind of Givens there JavaScript and
jeaious
and I feel like that's kind of like even
those are even though even though those
are blurred I think that those are
probably a given you would you'd
probably assume that those it would be
first two and then there was some in
here that were actually kind of
surprising for example node was a rule
further to the right and and that was to
the and then also there was which is
actually kind of interesting because it
actually came I believe came before it
was there was more NPM than node
significantly more NPM yeah it was like
a little further further apart from each
other on the chart which is actually
really interesting because you would
think that they would kind of be like a
little bit more equal because they can
only think when I think of note I think
also of NPM so it was that was a little
interesting but yeah so the the the
interesting thing about that even though
that we didn't really gather too much
about our about a who horse yes is from
from this chart we did we did kind of
confirm some of our assumptions for
example we thought we assumed that
horses web developer and the keywords
that we got from our aggregation and
this chart kind of confirmed some of
those stuff right and and once we figure
out who was that there was actually a
key piece of evidence in here that we're
not showing you that was actually like
yep of course it is
all right um so the last thing we
alright sources and this one's this
one's super interesting so remember we
talked about whenever you commit a crime
there's 20 pieces of evidence that you
leave behind that point directly to you
this is it so whenever you tweet just
FYI there is a sources property that you
are sending that is the origination of
your tweet and that could be the web
that could be your device your tablet
whatever it is you send a source to
Twitter and Twitter records that source
and horse jeaious is no exception it
recorded that source for them and lucky
for us that source was kind of
interesting on the left we have the web
client and on the right we have Android
now here's what's really interesting of
all those people in the chart that we
showed you before there's only a handful
using Android
and of all the six people that were our
suspects in New York there's only one
and this was the moment at Friday where
I said to Jasmine oh my gosh
we got him
so what do we know we know they're
located in New York we know that there
are certain subjects that they tweet
about more than others we have obscured
those results from you we know that they
are one of our six suspects and we know
that they use Android so with that and
some key information that we have not
shown you otherwise you'd be able to
piece this together for yourself are you
ready to find out who horse jeaious is
[Music]
so we kind of also have a public service
now if you decide to you know do this
repeat this experiment for either horse
chess or any another anonymous Twitter
account we just wanna let you know that
doxxing is not cool if you're going to
do it please be sure to protect people's
identities it's not it's not fair don't
bring a lot of unwanted attention to
people who might not want it so yeah
just be good ethical yeah exactly yeah
if people want to remain anonymous let's
let them remain anonymous we reached out
to horse yes and we said hey is it okay
if we get up on the stage and say your
name and they said yes absolutely yeah
we are here with permission yeah so I
think we're all set we're ready to
reveal so before we do we're gonna put
our horse mask there we go
all right do you want to do it selfie
yeah we're into yourself all right we're
did a selfie before do so okay this
thing smells so bad yeah I'm a hazard me
smelling like rubber I don't actually
don't know if we're gonna be able to
hear us but we're gonna try I can't see
this is impossible oh wait where are we
okay very good okay all right we're
gonna take a selfie so oh wait they're
gonna reverse the key ever again Oh oh
gosh get it there we go we're good yeah
all right one two three okay we can we
can I don't think in hearing aids its
muffling the horses success there we go
it actually looks better as a hat I
think so can we have a drumroll please
question stop stop
we're like we're at a time sorry we we
we we have to we have to do closing
remark need to get Brian sand clear up
here
[Applause]
thanks for not outing me I thought you
liked me no